cheers everybody it is time for cruise
news where we go spelunking in the good
news cavern and with me here is my human
news co-pilot rossi ross matthews hi
everybody hi
hi splunky
well guess what i'm very excited about
this first story um because
nobody does it like cardi b she's a
beautiful unicorn of a woman and people
report
that cardi says she really wants a new
tattoo of her baby's name
and she wants it on her face
right on her jawline
cardian rapper offset had a son in
september and they have yet to share his
name and this is certainly one way to
present it out into the world raw
thoughts okay i love the sentiment of
getting a tattoo with you that's sweet
cardi
now i can't get behind a face tattoo i
just can't do it
because here's the deal if you get a
tattoo of somebody's name don't you want
to look at it and see it but the only
way you could see this one is if you
looked in the mirror and then it'd be
backwards that's not going to work dear
that's just not going to work it's true
plus if you get like a name on a jawline
as you get older it's sort of so if you
get like right if you get like karen
here it's gonna be current
that's not cute that does worry me
and you do not strike me as the face
tattoo type so i
i guess girl you don't know me all right
almost
i'm a bad boy
you get on your harley at night and rev
that bad boy in your leather can you
imagine
oh my god i look like a village person
in chaps it's not gonna work nothing
wrong with that um all right so in honor
of cardi
i gave what will no you do not to if
they're not permanent oh thank god um
can you imagine
okay so i did frankie on this side which
would show what's a little longer
version if your child's name has more
than you know let's say four letters you
do one daughter on each side and then i
did olive on this side that i really
liked this placement because honestly
you don't even notice it very much and
my jawline is disintegrating every
single year
so but i'm not kidding it's giving me
like contour and i kind of love it and
if it's placed right i think this could
weirdly start a new trend i kind of get
it after i did it it sparked joy whereas
at first i was like no and then i was
like
and i'm in i especially the olive one
i'm
that's different
um
okay
i think
i think it's cuter than i thought it
would be that's the point it's just it's
not as jarring if somebody had that i'd
be like that's not bad
yeah okay i can understand a certain
person um
i would i would i want to draw one on me
right now just as if i put drew here it
just turned to droop you know what i
mean
all right well you thank you cardi for
giving me a new idea
all right well next we've got a little
culinary rumor cooking up food and wine
reports snoop dogg might be getting into
the hot dog business brilliant
yes he just they love it
he just filed a trademark application
for snoop dogg's with a double g i know
we we don't know snoop's plans yet but
he's already he's a businessman he's
already got in endogen
uh a snoop cali red wine and he already
owns the trademark for snoop scoops
who knows what he's gonna do with that
uh drew in the summer of 2022 could you
see yourself grilling a snoop dog
i would snap a snoop dogg i'll snap into
a snoop dogg snap into a snoop dogg i
would
that's the double og i'm looking for
thank you so much
so i'm in okay next up new year new
dating trend metro uk reports that
singles are
reincarnating and the approach is this
okay so maybe the last few years of the
pandemic and our entire world is being
flipped upside down turned inside out
and put in a washing machine
you know have made people have more time
to think about what they really want ran
card dating is an answer that is a total
rebirth of your dating life to match
your new outlook including possibly your
bio and refreshing your profile pics and
matching your new intentions with how
you execute that moving forward ross
thoughts well i think you know i always
said this before but dating is work you
have to
put in the time and effort to get what
you want and if you haven't found it yet
you're not doing something right so
refreshing it all coming at it with a
new approach is so smart and i think you
should take it a step further not just a
new profile picture or i agree i think
you need to delete the account and start
a fresh one think about this people have
already seen your account they've
already swiped by you for some reason so
reinvent yourself rein what is it
reincarnation
reincarnate yourself uh and maybe uh
someone who overlooked you before will
see you with fresh eyes okay i don't
know i've lost faith again with the
dating when did this happen
i i took a dip because it just there
it's just it it
i think
you refresh you know your own sort of
excitement about it too you go in and
you're like oh my god no wonder it's
like shooting fish in a barrel like
everybody's here where have i been
and then a few months later you're like
uh
this is so weird
you know as soon as you get into the
dating app i start to get frustrated
again it's hard it is hard it bums me
out to hear that you're sort of over it
because but i go in and out yeah i'm not
i am not i am not cynical i just when
you i just go in and out understood it's
like eating i eat a lot and then i reel
it in
you know oh
get on a dating app and i'll get excited
and then i'll be like you know what
i'm out again like i'm i'm a swing i'm a
swinger
well that might not go on my dating app
profile
delete delete delete delete hilarious
that's a real real incarnating
all right well next up anybody here
watch it euphoria on hbo yes
well it's finally back for a season two
uh wellington's obsessed with it well
we've got a makeup trend the show made
famous in style reports this year is all
about the crystal eye makeup and it's
added a little sparkle and glitz to your
eyes they do this on euphoria all the
time and celebrities are doing amanda
gorman machine gun kelly looking great
storm read sporting some sparkle and we
have some here and look it comes on
these little sheets and you could just
remove it
okay um let me see is it cute by the end
of this news i'm going to be very
adorned with neck tattoos
jawline tattoos
and
i
i've never felt more myself than i feel
right now okay now put your leather on
go get on your harley and rev on out of
here on your hog wait which one's me
i love it
[Music]
you